إنه أمر مخيف دائمًا عندما تسمع عن
وفاة شخص ما بسبب شيء شائع
مثل الأنفلونزا ،
فهناك أربع طرق رئيسية يمكن أن تتحول فيها الأنفلونزا
إلى مميتة ، وهي الأسباب الأولى والأكثر شيوعًا
للالتهاب الرئوي ، حيث يمكن لفيروس الإنفلونزا أن
يسبب الالتهاب الرئوي الفيروسي بشكل مباشر بمجرد إصابة
شخص ما بالإنفلونزا.
الجهاز المناعي لدرجة أن فيروس
أو بكتيريا أخرى يمكن أن تدخل الرئتين المصابة
تمتلئ الرئتين بالسوائل مما يجعل
التنفس صعبًا لذلك لا يمكن للأكسجين الوصول
إلى بقية الجسم مما قد يؤدي
إلى
تعفن الدم هو الطريقة الثانية التي يمكن أن
تصبح بها الأنفلونزا قاتلة  يحدث
تعفن الدم
بشكل خاص عند البالغين الأصحاء والأطفال عندما يذهب الجهاز المناعي للفرد
في محاولة لمحاربة
الأنفلونزا مما يسبب الالتهاب الذي يمكن أن
يؤدي إلى سلسلة من الأعراض التي
تنتهي في النهاية بفشل الأعضاء
، والطريقة الثالثة التي يمكن أن تقتلها الأنفلونزا هي عن طريق
زيادة  يقول الخبراء إن خطر الإصابة بنوبة قلبية
عند البالغين يزيد خطر الإصابة بنوبة
قلبية ستة أضعاف في الأيام السبعة
التالية لتشخيص الأنفلونزا ،
الطريقة الرابعة للإنفلونزا  يمكن أن تقتل عن طريق
الجفاف خاصة بين الرضع
والأطفال الصغار ، غالبًا ما تسبب الأنفلونزا
القيء والإسهال الذي يمكن أن
يهدد الحياة بسرعة إذا لم يتم
استبدال السوائل في الجسم ، لذلك إذا
أصبت بالإنفلونزا ، فمتى يجب أن تشعر بالقلق من
أن يعاني بعض الأشخاص من ارتفاع  خطر حدوث
مضاعفات خطيرة من الأنفلونزا بما في ذلك
الأطفال المسنين الذين تقل أعمارهم عن خمس
نساء حوامل وأولئك الذين يعانون من
مشاكل صحية مزمنة إذا كان هذا هو ذلك ، فتأكد
من مراجعة الطبيب إذا كنت
طفلًا أكبر سناً أو بالغًا احترس من
الدوخة الشديدة المفاجئة  قيء مستمر ،
صعوبة في التنفس ، ألم أو
ضغط في الصدر أو البطن
وأعراض شبيهة بالأنفلونزا تحسنها
تعود بحمى أو سعال أسوأ